[Musica]
quante volte da piccoli vi siete sentiti
dire no questo non si fa
e quando chiedevi perché ti veniva detto
perché non si fa oppure perché è
sbagliato
senza che ti venisse data una
spiegazione approfondita
[Musica]
la bambina abitavo con i miei nonni a
poggibonsi
avevo più o meno quattro anni
sentivo particolarmente la mancanza di
mia mamma
così un giorno decisi di andare a casa
sua che era dall'altra parte della città
mi incamminai arrivati davanti al
portone lo trovai aperto entrai mamma ma
non era in casa quindi mi mise a sedere
sulle scale e aspetta e rientrasse
ma invece di mamma arrivo nonno che mi
riporto a casa e al mio ritorno c'era
tutto il condominio e mi stava
aspettando una signora fosca si chiamava
mi disse una frase mi si sta un po in
testa
non lo farei mai più perché ti portano
via gli zingari
allora non capivo quello che diceva per
me non aveva senso oggi capisco
quanti timori e pregiudizi ci sono
ancora nei confronti del diverso di ciò
che non conosciamo
c'è sempre stato questo timore nei
confronti di persone appartenenti a una
cultura diversa dalla nostra o che
avevano un esperto un aspetto insolito o
un comportamento sociale non adeguato
per come sono cresciuto mi sento di dire
sono dalla parte dei freak di quegli
elementi della società che non si
inquadrano in un contesto ben preciso e
che per questo motivo vengono emarginati
a volte preso come bersaglio di critiche
nei casi peggiori come soggetti sui
quali sfogare la propria rabbia
quegli elementi della società che de
andrè ampiamente descritto nei suoi
brani
e per questo amo il lavoro di diane
arbus diane arbus una fotografa
americana
vissuta tra gli anni venti e gli anni
settanta del novecento che ha deviato la
sua fotografia ai fricka appunto a
questi soggetti ai margini della società
interrogandosi su cosa fosse la
normalità chi e cosa è normale
per lo stesso motivo ho deciso di
fotografare mia madre
è normale
che cosa è vero
che cosa è bello
prima la bellezza era questa
una bellezza molto diversa quella cui
siamo abituati oggi
fin da piccoli cresciamo con una serie
di norme di nomi e di convenzioni che ci
si attaccano addosso fino a diventare la
nostra seconda pelle parte della nostra
identità
che siano canoni di bellezza
il sistema di informazione le abitudini
alimentari
l'impianto religioso l'impianto
economico cresciamo in un contesto in
cui tutto ciò che rientra all'interno di
questi parametri risulta normale ciò che
si discosta strano diverso e questo è
anche il motivo di del nascere di
pregiudizi e gli stereotipi
perché se vediamo un arabo con una
valigetta in mano su un mezzo di
trasporto pubblico
pensiamo che sia un terrorista
perché ci facciamo ancora problemi se
una persona il colore della pelle
diverso dal nostro o se una persona a
tratta da una persona dello stesso sesso
questi discorsi e questi concetti sono
sentiti e risentiti se ne parla di
continuo e sempre a ognuno di noi lì con
di vita sembrava ognuno di noi sia
d'accordo sul fatto che non sia giusto
discriminare altre persone
però perché allora ci sono ancora
divisioni disuguaglianze e violenze
dovute a queste disuguaglianze
questo si chiama perbenismo a me il
perbenismo non piace
che cosa facciamo nel concreto ogni
giorno per cambiare le cose
rispettiamo davvero profondamente il
prossimo
abbiamo davvero una mente aperta e
pronta ad accogliere
io penso che sia dovere di ognuno di noi
non solo di fare un mestiere creativo di
ricopre ruoli importanti penso sia
dovere di ognuno di noi mettere e
mettersi in discussione farsi domande
imparare a guardare le cose da più punti
di vista
cercare di conoscere ciò che non
conosciamo perché su questi principi che
si basa la comprensione dell'accoglienza
e poi alla fine per cambiare le cose non
c'è da fare chissà che basta una cosa il
rispetto
il rispetto in tutte le sue forme
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]